it's been two and a half years since Ted
wave fled Hong Kong the former
pro-democracy politician now lives in
Exile in Australia the Hong Kong
government has issued a warrant for his
arrest it's uh sending a white Terror
message through me saying that oh
whoever who are still criticizing the
CCP China and whoever who are resisting
and fighting for freedoms you are now at
trouble you are now under threat I think
that's a very clear message to the world
Ted white is one of eight pro-democracy
activists being pursued by the Hong Kong
government which has offered a bounty of
130 000 as a reward for information that
leads to their arrest we'll do whatever
legally
to Pursuit be responsible person the
group is accused of violating the
sweeping National Security laws which
Beijing imposed on the former British
colony in 2020 in a bid to stop the
protests the only reason I can think of
why they would be doing this is because
they've run out of pipelines of National
Security cases because a lot of those
cases the trials are nearly finished or
are about to start and they're just
looking for new villains to justify the
huge budget that's been given to them so
it's economics as much as Politics the
city's political system has also been
overhauled Hong Kong lawmakers have
passed an amendment to a law that
eliminates most directly elected seats
on Local District councils those
councils were the last major political
representative bodies chosen by the
public all incoming councilors will be
vetted by a committee to ensure Patriots
are governing the city I would say it's
directing political participation it is
moving to a harder form of
authoritarianism
a song that became the unofficial anthem
for the pro-democracy protest movement
in 2019 is also being targeted Hong
Kong's department of justice has filed a
civil injunction to have it banned we're
seeing this outright attempt to ban
and you know it is a sign of the
vulnerability of the Hong Kong
government if they are scared of
something like a song critics say it's
yet another form of censorship three
years after the national security law
was introduced there have been 160
prosecutions Sarah Clark Al Jazeera